ciao ragazzi bene così alla prima
puntata di law con una voce ormai siamo
bombardati dai modi perché ci giriamo il
solo e modi da tutte le parti ma andiamo
in moggi ei gruppi la famiglia [ __ ]
però le amiche quando affrontiamo con un
ragazzo quindi ecco perché non fare una
serie di video dove andrò ad analizzare
e appunto i significati più nascosti di
queste nostre amiche e musi in
particolare il video di oggi vuole
andare a studiare da vicino quali sono
le voci che non dovete mai inviare ad
una ragazza ecco ragazzi
aprite bene le orecchie queste sono le
voci che non ci dovete dirlo con un e
musi alla roma uno abbiamo lei
ecco vi farò segreto cari ragazzi in
ascolto se ci mandate un messaggio corto
ci ringraziano
se invece mandare un messaggio forte
cima al mese con legge in su
avete chiuso
e poi c'è quel giorno quel fantastico
momento dove noi aspettiamo un vostro
messaggio torino dolce e romantico c'è
qualcuno che se ne esce con buongiorno
con il sole che come mi puoi dire che
porge il sole lo vedo anch'io che io
sono consone la sedicente un modo
sbagliato che tu sei allegro e quindi
per me no
ma c'è qualcosa terzo del sole
incominciamo andato con la manina lei
ciao buongiorno e poi ci sono i baci
ecco se siamo fidanzati bacio e utilizzo
con cuore sembra manchi senza cuore vuol
dire che una relazione sta subendo
qualcosa di terribile dobbiamo parlarne
non parlare subito ma se non siamo
ancora piazza che siamo solo per quel
tanto e con questi sono i tre baci che
proprio non ci dovete mandare nello spi
dico ammazzate 6 sprecato può evitare di
mandare una sto punto il fischio ma mi
stai rischiando questa da che cosa mi
rappresenta
6 soffiando e non c'è chi bacino con le
gote rosse che imparino che dolce sa fa
il timido e poi però dopo due messaggi
che ne esci con una di queste cose ma lo
ritrovano insieme partiamo da lei
sei un corso nella linguetta di fuori
che carina un gelatino è l'unica cosa
che a me oppure è parliamo di lei 6
posso farlo voi fa richiesta lingua di
fuori occhiolino io è spostati
oppure ancora peggio lei
che cos'è un cane c'è un cagnolino
scodinzoli pure il pecorino portami a
palline proposito i piani c'è anche lei
che cos'è stata quella buona fissa e
fame quando si messaggio silvio horta
capita di non riuscire a un messaggio
magari sto facendo altro tesoro è
costretto in quel preciso istante di
bari una di queste mogi crei sono una
cosa e poi sono i ragazzi che sentono
molto ghetto mood quindi rimandano quasi
a scialla oppure pugnetto is back
ma cosa sono la tua sorella la costa del
ghetto si vivano quel che tu non vieni a
e poi arriva quel momento in cui tu vai
a ballare coi temi che è il ragazzo che
quelli stai sentendo frequentando vuole
assicurarsi che tu faccia la brava chi
scrive questa frase che ci provoca
sempre un po di nausea mi raccomando fai
la brava e l'accompagna sempre da queste
masi lanciò la carriera di solito perché
ti mandano questa fase queste mogis a
quelli che non fanno nei bravi
e poi arriva momento tra buonanotte
momento più dolci più tenero della
giornata dove noi aspettiamo tanto con
ansia questo messaggino e ci arriva
questo fa e tanta nato pure buon in che
cosa o tre anni
di solito accompagnato da queste cose il
ronzio di un calabrone ho detto tutto
per me no
eccoci quindi arrivati alla fine della
prima puntata di law con una pausa spero
tanto vi sia piaciuto il video vorrei
che i commenta se qua sotto di cedere
quale le voci che un ragazzo proprio non
mi deve mandare se mi è piaciuto il
figlio ricordatevi di mettere likes
iscrivervi al canale e ovviamente di
seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
facebook instance chatel musicali dopo
d'oro di lavoro le mose